This is a fascinating, yet heartbreaking case, but it's a great way to start
this lesson because it shows us just how important our memory is to us as well
as our families. Now imagine being one of H. M.'s family members and watching
him struggle with these profound memory problems. Or being one of the people
that he can't remember. That would be really difficult to deal with. Now even
though H.M. had profound amnesia, he was well aware of his memory problems. He
described it as constantly waking up from a dream he couldn't remember. Henry
Molaison contributed a great deal to the study of memory, as well as the areas
of the brain that are associated with forming and retrieving memories. After
his death, his brain was donated to a group of researchers at the University of
California San Diego. Who provided imaging of his brain tissue to map the
brain. If you're interested on learning more, we provided a link to their
website. It's really fascinating, you should check it out. Now HM showed us
just how important our memory is for us to function as successful human beings
in our everyday environment. Psychologists look at a lot of different types of
memory, but let's get started with just some of the basics for now.